hello and welcome to drive at the motor
magazine on DW this time we test the
Mercedes C 43 AMG stationwagon
celebrate the world endurance
championship season finale with Porsche
in Bahrain and go for a spin in the new
Audi a8
howdy is rolling out its fourth
generation a eighth and breaking with
quite a few traditions an active driver
no need at least not in certain
situations like traffic jams it's also
thrown away the key test driver young
Stockmann says it's often the attention
to details that makes a car so
interesting we're all familiar with the
electronic key fobs for locking and
unlocking the car and starting the
engine those are being replaced by
smartphones other people can use it to
your partner your children and in the
future even delivery services which can
simply put whatever you ordered into the
trunk of the car
Dimitri I'm 40 bestowed in Van Winkle
form of Lincoln the new a8 also has more
than 40 different assistant systems
onboard and four systems supply them
with information radar sensors a front
camera ultrasound sensors and a laser
scanner allow the car to get a full
picture of its surroundings
all the combustion engines are supported
by electric drivetrains a belt-driven
starter generator is part of the
standard mild hybrid system at the rear
there's more to discover than just the
snazzy lighting design dents explains
that the naming strategy is new this is
the 55 TFSI Quattro with a 3 liter v6
engine
it's a gasoline driven car with 340
horsepower but with hybridization or
electromobility howdy is no longer
putting the engine size on the car the
numbers do still indicate the vehicles
performance smaller numbers represent
lower and larger numbers greater
performance that all goes back to the
Chinese market before this numbering has
already been introduced there's a choice
between a 210 kilowatt diesel model and
a 250 kilowatts strong gasoline model
which we tested thanks to the mild
hybrid technology fuel consumption has
been reduced by 0.7 liters per 100
kilometers at speeds between 55 and 160
km/h the car is able to coast with the
engine switched up driving emissions
free for 40 seconds at a time
hence finds that despite the Audi a8
considerable length it handles well on
winding roads you barely notice how long
the car is thanks to the dynamic
all-wheel steering
that allows the steering angles on the
front and rear axles of the 5.17 metre
vehicle to be set individually in
addition the body sits on an intelligent
active chassis along with a presense
360-degree system that enhances passive
safety like this
is impressed he calls it a benchmark for
the new Audi age in case of a collision
the vehicle raises itself up by eighty
millimeters before impact the headrests
are adjusted and the seat belts
tightened that's certainly an innovation
and safety the sensors detect every
movement around the car the a8 has its
watchful eye on more vulnerable road
users - ends explains that another
highlight among the assistance systems
is one that prevents you from opening
the door when a bike riders approaching
from behind the feature is on all the
doors which is likely to appeal to
parents to find the car can even see
around corners the intersection
assistance senses vehicles approaching
from the side log before they appear in
the driver's field of view the bike
rider is shown in advance in the display
and the car stops if the driver doesn't
react with all that tech the a8 sets new
standards and active and passive safety
protecting everyone moving near it the
Audi and says this premium luxury sedan
is really spacious including in the
trunk he's impressed by all the
assistance systems and hopes that many
of them are installed in outies other
ranges of class and fun Aldi Bankim
the a8 starts at 90 thousand euros in
Germany an additional 3,500 euros gets a
longer wheelbase and next year the mild
hybrid models are to be joined by a
plug-in hybrid
there's almost as cart tester running
let's take points out nearly all
automakers have especially sporty
vehicles in their ranges with Mercedes
the letters AMG denote that class of car
today Ronnie's testing the C 43 AMG
stationwagon
the C 43 is basically the little brother
of the c63 AMG which costs about 17
thousand euros more what distinguishes
the C 43 is its powerful 3 litre v6
biturbo engine and it's all-wheel drive
the list price in Germany starts at
61850 euros the greatest difference to
the c63 AMG is in the engineering since
the c63 only comes with rear-wheel drive
and under the hood it's got a 4 liter v8
biturbo engine with 70 kilowatts more
power and a fuller sound
even if the c43 loses a few points in
comparison its status as the strongest
c-class with all-wheel-drive is
uncontested its v6 twin-turbo engine
accelerates from 0 to 100 km/h in just
4.8 seconds and boasts a maximum speed
of 250 km/h fuel consumption varies
according to wheel size our test car
uses an average of 8.1 liters per 100
kilometers making the smaller AMG
theoretically more fuel efficient than
the larger model by 0.3 litres a diamond
pattern grill and the AMG front apron
with its distinctive air intakes are
among the design elements that when the
exterior an even more dynamic character
in addition the c43 has adopted much of
its suspension technology from his big
brother the large brakes are a further
indication of the car's high performance
the rear has an understated spoiler and
a sport exhaust system with two twin
tailpipes that not only add to the
impressive sound but help set aesthetic
accents the interior is decked out in
black leather and microfiber with red
stitching and access the center console
both shiny design elements made of
carbon fiber
the optional performance front seats
offer optimal lateral support Ronnie
thinks the c43 AMG is a good choice if
you want to see class as an AMG but at a
lower price it doesn't have the c63 AMG
s v8 biturbo engine but this v6 is just
as fun and much more fuel efficient
after the grand sports sedan and the
sports tourer station wagon opals
rolling out yet another insignia model
the country a station wagon with higher
clearance the top-of-the-range model
comes with a 2 litre 191 kilowatt
turbocharged engine and an 8-speed
automatic transmission the country tour
with the smallest gasoline engine lists
at about 35,000 euros in Germany 10
years after its first GS model BMW Motor
watt has thoroughly revamped its travel
and duros the updated design looks more
dynamic even downright masculine the GS
models have 70 kilowatts of power
suitable both for touring and
off-roading the F 850 gs with more
performance was at 11700 euros in
Germany
the World Endurance Championship reached
its finale and Porsche bade farewell to
the LeMond prototype one class at the
2017 six hours of buffeted it's a very
emotional day for Porsche and a
wonderful time it's a highlight for his
career as a Porsche driver and he feels
more pride and joy than sadness Porsche
had already nailed the world
championship title in the season's next
to last race in Shanghai but the team
wasn't ready to rest on its laurels
it's never easy we obviously want to do
the best that we can and hopefully
chance for the win
Portia's only competitor in the lmp1
class was Toyota yeah well we're going
into this race to try and win we've won
four races this year in car number eight
but the competitors drove hard to the
very end endurance racing demands
everything from the team's Lemann driver
han soo-ah from stroke endurance racing
his good fun and teamwork from the first
driver to the last mechanic everyone has
to work together to win he points out
that after Formula One the WEC is the
technically and most demanding series he
has lots of fun with all the classes
lmp1 lmp2 GTE & GT they bring everything
together with the latest technology even
with the stress leading up to the start
the drivers still find time for their
fans you'll get a chance to collect
autographs during what's known as the
pit walk
this part of the racing event appeals to
young and old alike in the last two
minutes of the qualifying rounds Porsche
managed to secure positions one and
three Toyota claimed two and four
driver Neil Johnny was a bit surprised
himself they got quite a run for their
money against Toyota in the qualifying
and weren't expecting to earn their pole
positions in the very last race as the
Sun descends over Bahrain that cars are
off the second portion takes the lead in
the very first curve with such big
variations in performance between the
four classes many of the cars end up
lapping each other which makes it more
exciting but can also complicate matters
speed is of the essence for pit stops -
teamwork and precision mean everything
here tires have to be changed and the
tank filled before the car heads back
onto the track
the race is head-to-head with the four
lmp1 cars constantly jockeying for
position
as the hours tick past the suspense
rises in the Porsche pit flat tires and
flattened cones on the tracks load the
Porsches down the number 8 Toyota takes
home the victory while Porsche lands 2nd
and 3rd even so the Porsche team has
reason to celebrate
their results from three years in the
lmp1 are three Lemann outright victories
plus three manufacturers and three
drivers world championship titles
welcome Porsche sees it as an incredible
success thanks in part to a healthy dose
of luck he's sure his father would have
been especially happy he always said
that they had to do motorsports because
they got so many innovations and
improvements from it and so it pays off
Kutty cow's skin side
ashell steiner predicts they'll keep
driving their 911s at least as
intensively and the GTS even more so
Porsche intends to reflect its product
strategy for a move toward electric
drive in Motorsports as well so they've
decided in addition to building the
mission a production car to pursue
motorsports and the formula e electric
auto racing
Mazda has its own way of doing things
instead of finding an original name with
a deeper meaning it calls its smallest
model simply to choose fourth-generation
has been the number four car buyers to
remember since 2014 and rather than
sticking to well-trodden paths it too
goes its own way
the artist contest ahan deletes moment
points to the engine as the major
difference to other super minis mazda
has completely dispensed with turbo
charging which in his view has the
disadvantage of the gas pedal feeling a
bit sluggish that's because it doesn't
achieve maximum torque until 4000 rpms
but an advantage is that since the air
isn't compressed by the turbocharger the
engine's response is a little more
direct than missing detect on the specs
are nothing to be ashamed of the two
accelerates from 0 to 100 km/h in less
than 10 seconds unmatched by most other
super minis with comparable engines an
average fuel consumption of 4.5 liters
per 100 kilometers is also quite
acceptable on do i points out another of
the mazda twos unique selling points
it's the lightweight construction the
entry-level model
tips the scale at under a ton even with
more equipment the Mazda 2 is still one
to two hundred kilos lighter than its
competitors that means better fuel
efficiency and handling the fafa head
north Mazda sums it all up with a term
gram strategy meaning it cuts every
single unnecessary gram and that adds up
to over 100 kilogram saved the twos
special engine technology carries the
trade name sky active
the interior on the other hand isn't
about cutting and saving at all it
hardly looks any different from the
inside of higher range models
immediately noticeable is the glossy
black and metallic trim down the length
of the dashboard
in Gondry especially likes the controls
for the infotainment system a rotating
dial on the center console normally he
only sees these in higher priced
vehicles such as the audi a1 competition
of course the quality doesn't compare
but Andrei thinks it's refreshing to see
controls that don't resemble a
smartphone on the contrary but car
owners who just can't do without a
touchscreen don't need to worry the
monitor can function that way too
normally when the car is not moving that
things go smoothly some stunts
unfortunately the Mazda 2 doesn't offer
any way for a smartphone to connect with
the car using Android auto or apple
carplay
but at least for a small charge it
offers a phone holder or when the driver
uses it as a sat-nav
Andrei is certain the Mazda 2 has enough
unique selling points to pull ahead of
the competition and enough in common to
be a factor in the compact class for
example and fairs compact body
proportions with a long wheelbase to
make for a roomier interior the 2 is
ideal for relaxed driving without any
unnecessary gadget tree and that's just
what many car buyers are looking for the
Mazda 2 lists for about 13,000 euros in
Germany the version we tested costs
about 5,000 euros more but there's no
need to hide it this is by no means a
bad choice for a small car segment
today our classic car expert Christoph
Bauer is taking an unusual American car
out for a spin the Chevrolet Corvair
Monza Spyder most American cars of its
era boasted oversized bodies and a big
engine up front ideally a v8 but not the
Corvair
Christophe says in the 1950 sales of
European cars rose massively in the US
especially those of the VW Beetle it was
the polar opposite of the kinds of
vehicles American manufacturers had in
our portfolios at the time suddenly its
design and technology was considered
modern progressive even hip but the
American response to this demand was
soon to arrive it came in 1959 and was
called the Chevrolet Corvair by American
standards the Corvair was a compact even
though at almost 4.6 meters it's longer
than a Mercedes Ponton and at 6-cylinder
boxer engine with close to 100
horsepower didn't while power-hungry
American drivers that much either but
they were impressed by where the engine
was located the Chevy Corvair was the
only American car of its day powered by
a rear engine christoph says this exotic
looking car was surprisingly successful
more than 250,000 rolled off the
assembly lines in the first year alone
and things got even better when Chevy
introduced the Monza option with a floor
shift bucket seats larger hubcaps and a
bit more chrome it was named after the
Italian racing circuit McClung for
nominate a mistake
soon Chevrolet was selling more Monza's
than standard models the only thing
missing was a stronger engine but not
for long as Christophe explains 1962
Chevrolet presented an additional option
the Spyder and it was truly sensational
the first series production car to
feature a turbocharged engine it's 150
horsepower propels the car from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour and ten point three
seconds with a top speed of 165
kilometers an hour the turbo boost is
only really effective in a relatively
small range between 3,000 and 3800 rpm
but then it really kicks in to make sure
drivers can master and keep an eye on
this innovative technology the dashboard
features what christoph figures is
likely the first boost pressure
indicator in automotive history though
it tops out at just 0.7 bar which he
finds touching
as I'm he's going but it wasn't just the
Corvairs technology that set new
standards so did its design this accent
line which wraps around the entire body
came to be known as the Corvair line
this design feature was later adopted by
European manufacturers like BMW the
Corvairs design is a pleasant contrast
to the American cars of the late 1950s
with their huge tail fins and radiator
grilles it's clean lines and purest as
I'm proved that sometimes less really is
more the Chevy Corvair was also
versatile in addition to the Schick
coupe a the Corvair was also available
as a four-door sedan a convertible a
station wagon a pickup and even a van
known as the core van but chevrolet
offered the turbo engine exclusively in
the coupe a and convertible versions
the Monza spider came with five round
gauges and a brushed aluminum instrument
panel and a stick shift only giving it
the feel of a true blue American sports
car but as I cristo says the Monza
spiders real highlight lies here under
the hood it's 2.7 liter turbocharged
engine
the first series production turbo and
automotive history - paddle wheels
rotate inside this casing here driven by
the exhaust and then press the air and
gas mixture into the combustion chamber
this engine delivers up to 70 more
horsepower than the normally aspirated
one and all for a bargain price in its
day the Spyder package cost just 297
dollars extra it looks great
unfortunately it doesn't always work so
well it took Porsche and Saab till
finally attained in the turbo the
Corvairs engine transmission and drive
gears are wrapped in one compact package
the Uni pack power team though this
construction doesn't exactly inspire
confidence
still it's turbo Technology boosted
chevy sales in 1962 more than 300,000
Corvairs were sold making it the most
successful year in the model's history
the crew staff knows that there was a
small problem with the Corvair or those
who drove it
unlike the solid and steady front engine
boats Americans were used to driving the
rear engine Corvair had a dynamic but
somewhat temperamental driving style and
some people couldn't cope with that
especially on hard turns the cars rear
would jack up causing the wheel to tuck
under the car to oversteer and the rear
end to swing out to combat this effect
chevrolet specified different pressures
for the front and back tires but many
buyers thought this was just a misprint
in their owners manual so the Corvair
was headed for disaster investors and in
love
Chevrolet soon found itself facing more
than 100 lawsuits resulting from serious
accidents the automaker worked
frantically to make the car safer
modifying the suspension and adding
better drum brakes but it was too little
too late
Christophe says the Corvairs fate was
sealed in 1965 when consumer advocate
and lawyer Ralph Nader published his
book unsafe at any speed in it he called
the Corvair the most dangerous vehicle
on the road
sales plummeted and a 1969 production of
the Corvair ceased entirely Christophe
thinks that's a real shame for him it's
trend-setting design and its status as
the first turbocharged mass production
model make the Corvair Monza spider a
milestone in automotive history and my
understand the automobile you see there
in 1965 the Corvair range got a new body
and the turbocharged engine was no
longer offered quickly and quietly
Chevrolet relegated its pioneering
series production turbo model to the
history books
next time on drive it we test
Mitsubishi's new coupe a style SUV the
eclipse cross
and head to California to take a look
around the Los Angeles Auto Show
you